so Facebook yesterday stepped up its
censorship campaign in one giant purge
they permanently banned a number of high
profile accounts the band includes Miley
innopolis Lara Loomer Paul Joseph Watson
along with Farrakhan and a few others
but it goes beyond that even because
Facebook banned any representation of
these people meaning you can't you can't
share content by them so no in for
Infowars content is allowed on Facebook
at all anymore
no Alex Jones content presumably nothing
produced by Milo or Watson either so a
facebook spokesperson said that in in in
explaining this sudden purge of people
who all coincidentally except for except
for Farrakhan happened to exist on the
right end of the spectrum explaining
that they said that the spokesperson
said that these people were banned for
quote engaging in violence or hate
Facebook also said that they are
dangerous and and then there's a report
on the BBC's website which has more
information it says a spokesperson at
Facebook said the ban will apply to all
types of representation of the
individuals on both Facebook and
Instagram the firm said it would remove
pages groups and accounts set up to
represent them and would not allow the
promotion of events when it knows the
banned individual is participating so
you can't even promote an event if one
of these guys are going to be there in
an email or woman as well Laura Loomer
in an email Facebook explained its its
rationale for banning the users listen
to this it said it said Alex Jones had
hosted on his program
Gavin McGinnis leader of the proud boys
who although I believe Gavin has stepped
down from the prowl boys I think whose
members are this according to reading
now from the BBC whose members are known
for racist anti-muslim and misogynistic
rhetoric mr. McGuiness has been
designated a hate figure by Facebook
Facebook said this year Milo Yan a
police had publicly praised both mr.
McGinnis and
English Defence League founder Tommy
Robinson both bands from the network
Laurel umer also appeared with mr.
McGinnis and Facebook said she also
praised another band figure faith Goldie
a Kaden a Canadian Nation of Islam a
Canadian sorry I'm I almost set a
Canadian nation of Islam leader I'm
blending sentences together next
sentence Nation of Islam leader Louis
Farrakhan was banned for making several
anti-semitic remarks earlier this year
okay I haven't this is just I'm it's
somewhat bewildering so Milo is banned
according to Facebook because he spoke
positively in public about Gavin
McGinnis so that's a violation of the
rules now if you express support in
public not even on Facebook but just
anywhere in public if you express
support for someone that Facebook is
targeted then you'll be banned also
that's what they're saying these are the
the sins committed by these individuals
that Facebook mentions but if these
people really have violated the rules
then why are you banning them all on the
same day why are you doing this big
dramatic thing where your frog marching
them in front of the cameras um if
you're just objectively enforcing the
rules whatever they may be then wouldn't
you a band you know Paul when he
violated those rules whenever that was
and wouldn't you have banned Milo
whenever he happened to violate those
rules whenever that was
and Alex Jones whenever he violated them
now you know with Alex Jones that Alex
Jones was banned on Facebook like a year
ago right but now it's going even
further that if you're if you're you
know his his website everything if
you're associated with him
no no content associated with him is
allowed on the site well you know I
think they could have Facebook could
have made an argument for banning Alex
Jones back when he was promoting the
insane Sandy Hook conspiracy theory
which led to death threats against the
parents of Murdered Children and it was
a conspiracy theory that was completely
invented and believed excluse
we buy morons and brain-dead idiots
so just be really clear about that it
was a not only a not only a stupid
conspiracy theory but a really evil
despicable one which led to as I said
the targeting of parents whose children
had just been murdered and now they have
they have these whack jobs coming after
them now look that was five years ago
though so if while alex jones was
promoting that conspiracy theory which
he did if they had said no we're not
allowing this on this this is you know
false information it's it's dangerous to
the peak to the parents who are now
being targeted for violence we're not
gonna allow it on our platform and we're
gonna ban you for promoting if they had
done that then we could say okay well
that's that seems like a consistent
enforcement of the rules doesn't appear
to be politically motivated but they
didn't is the point they they didn't do
anything when we NEET when this when
this conspiracy theory was actually
being promoted on facebook they didn't
do anything about it
five years later retro actively they
decided to punish him for past sins and
that to me seems to be a problem so you
know why did you wait five years if
you're gonna ban milo why are you
banning him now why did you wait until
now to do it what has he done recently
to earn this oh that's right he spoke in
support of gavin i mean he spoke he said
something nice about gavin McGinnis well
that makes sense right no it doesn't but
even if that's the reason why didn't you
ban him whenever he said that I'm pretty
sure I assume Milo as publicly he's
appeared in public with Gavin McGinnis
in the past so if that if that's a
violation of the rules why don't you ban
him as soon as he did it and you know
Paul Joseph Watson what what has he ever
done to earn a ban I mean whatever it
was whenever it was why not ban him when
it happened well the answer here of
course is that this is a PR stunt by
Facebook
the reason why they don't give more
specific reasons for the band's other
than this weird thing about Gavin
McGinnis is that they don't have
specific reasons this is political
censorship they're saying that Paul
Joseph Watson engages in violence or
hatred they don't give any examples of
it whatsoever because there are no
examples they don't have any examples
this is political censorship plain and
simple
yeah they tossed farrakhan in there
because they needed to have someone if
they're gonna do this big thing they
need to have somebody who's not you know
on the on the quote far-right although
the media has tried to lump Farrakhan in
with the far right as a far-right figure
which of course is ridiculous
Farrakhan is a leftist but but he's kind
of his own weird thing too right the
fact is Facebook they don't target
people who are really associated with
the with the actual far-left
know that this is all focused on one
side and I could go through a laundry
list of far-left accounts on Facebook
right now that are that are on Facebook
and they're spreading far-left content
hateful extremist whatever but let's
just remember I could there there are
many examples but let's let's remember
one just from this past week because we
just talked about it recently and
remember we talked about this here's the
picture again that's an account a
Facebook account run by a burlesque
performer and there she is half-naked
with a young girl stuffing dollar bills
into her underwear okay that was posted
on Facebook that picture and the picture
was taken down but as far as I know it
was taken down by the person who posted
it not by Facebook and this account
which proudly depicts the exploitation
and abuse of children is still on
Facebook so that's not what you just saw
there in that picture okay that that's
not dangerous
that's not extremist or whatever no that
that's okay and why is that because she
she's a burlesque performer who who's
you know promoting public nudity and and
you know sect the sexualization of
children that is a far left a gender
item and so that's why face book leaves
as it leaves it alone so there are two
questions fix my microphone there are
two questions that we have to ask here
about this number one is is Facebook
right in censoring these people and the
second is does Facebook have the right
to censor them and those are two
different questions with not necessarily
the same answer but whatever the answer
is to number two before we get to that I
think the answer to number one is very
clear that no they are not right in
doing it and every conservative should
be up in arms about this speaking out
about it because this is absolutely
political censorship facebook says that
it will ban people who are dangerous and
hateful yet the only litmus test
apparently for what's considered
dangerous and hateful is ideological so
by their standards you are dangerous and
hateful or you're at least close to
being dangerous and hateful if you're on
the right so you can hope that they eat
you last you can hope that you could eat
and last but you will get eaten if
you're a conservative
I think that's becoming clear the
problem is that some conservatives as
I've been watching the reaction from
other so-called prominent conservatives
is that I I see some of them who are
basically saying well I don't like Alex
Jones
I don't like Paul or Milo so so I'm fine
with this you know I'm not gonna say
anything about this because I don't like
those particular guys that is very
short-sighted thinking right there again
it would be entirely different in my
view if Facebook had clear rules clear
terms of service and they enforce those
rules equally now that would be
different if Facebook decided they were
gonna ban everyone who has extreme views
everyone who could be called hateful
everyone who is radical and what
you then then okay the site would be
boring as hell in that case because all
the interesting people would be gone but
at least it would be consistent and then
Facebook will become a place kind of
like LinkedIn or something just a just a
bland sort of meeting place where
basically no ideas are welcome and if
that's what they decided they want to do
then you know I think there would be no
room to complain but when it comes to
when it claims to be a forum for the
exchange of ideas and it claims to be
not politically biased but then it
labels only those on one side as being
hateful and dangerous and extreme and
then bans them bans them in one big PR
stunt
smearing them in the media in the
process that's a whole different
ballgame so as for the second question
do they have the right to do this well
I'll say one thing I don't see how a
company as powerful as Facebook has the
right to smear anyone as being dangerous
and hateful without justification or
reason okay that seems like libel to me
like defamation and it has a very real
effect on people's lives this is not
this is not just a you know any old
person saying oh your hate it's not just
some Twitter troll say oh you're hateful
and dangerous when you've got one of the
most powerful companies in the world
blacklist than you and then going to the
media and saying these are violent
hateful dangerous people that that's
gonna affect your life that's gonna
affect your career that's gonna have a
devastating effect on you and not just
because you don't have a Facebook
account anymore I mean you know try
getting a job when you have been
publicly smeared by the most power one
of most powerful companies and the
companies in the world as dangerous and
hateful think about how that's gonna
affect your professional prospects so if
you're gonna make those kinds of claims
about someone I think you need to
provide evidence you need to provide
justification and just giving a couple
of examples of some of these people you
know hanging out with Gavin McGinnis
that's not enough okay that's that's
that
not going to do it Facebook does not
have the right to defame anyone any more
than anyone else has the right to do it
if they have evidence to support the
claim that Paul Joseph Watson is
dangerous and hateful and violent then
they should present it
if they can't present it then I think
Paul has a case against them because
they're defaming him so that's the first
thing now
as for their right to ban whoever they
want
even on a politically motivated
ideological basis well that kind of
hinges on what Facebook is exactly and
that's that's the debate right and so
you'll hear you'll hear arguments about
whether Facebook is just a platform or
is it a publisher or is it a public
utility if there are utility like the
phone company then know they can't ban
just anyone they want from using their
their platform are they a utility well I
can you know I I can see the argument
for it after all phones are a utility
and and they're a communication tool
Facebook is a communication tool used by
over a billion people across the globe
on the other hand you could argue that
Facebook is really just an app on your
phone so it's more like a channel on
your television not the cable provider
itself thus not a utility I tend to side
with that point of view are they a
publisher though well if they're
exercising this kind of editorial
control that would seem to make them a
publisher trouble is if they're a
publisher then they're gonna be
responsible for everything that's posted
on their site and they don't want to be
responsible for that they don't want to
be responsible for it for all of it
but if they don't wanna be responsible
for it then then they need to be just a
platform just a kind of benign you know
stage that's provided upon which people
can stand and and express their views
but if they're just a platform then they
can't exercise this kind of editorial
control over it if they are exercising
tutorial control then
makes them a publisher so the trouble
seems to me that Facebook is dancing
between all of these different lines a
one-minute it's a publisher the next
it's a platform the next it's utility I
think it has to be one thing or the
other it has to decide what it is and
then it has to behave that way it seems
to me for now though I will say that
sure they have the right to ban people
generally speaking but they don't have
the right to smear anyone without basis
and putting rights aside and looking
instead at what is right this is not
right what they're doing here is not
right it's it's not a war on extremism
it's not an effort to stop hate okay
it's not any of that this is political
censorship plain and simple that's what
it is and we need to be speaking up
against it all right so a woman posted
this on Twitter approvingly posted I
should add it's a photo of a lecture
slide from some class not sure not sure
where I assumed a college class and
anyway look at this the slide lists what
it calls characteristics of white
supremacy and it lists characteristics
of white supremacy and it lists among
other things as a characteristic white
supremacy it lists objectivity and then
as you can see other kind of banal or
positive quality being objective I would
think is a positive thing the idea of
objectivity being a characteristic of
white supremacy is apparently it's a
thing now on the left this isn't the
first time I've seen this in fact I
remembered I had to go look it up
because I remembered seeing this in an
article it was on a national review a
few months ago and just the first few
sentences of the article say a course
that will be taught at Hobart and
William Smith Colleges next year will
teach students that objectivity
meritocracy our exam objectivity of
meritocracy are examples of white
mythologies and social constructs the
description for the class says this
course explores the history
ongoing manifestations of white
mythologies long-standing often implicit
views about the place of white male
euro-american subjects as the norm
against which the peoples of the world
are to be understood and judged
the class has titled white mythologies
objectivity meritocracy and other social
constructions now I'm not sure if this
slide is a is from that particular class
or not but either way here's the point
white supremacy does exist in this world
there are real white supremacists there
are real white racists out there we have
seen them I don't think there are a lot
of them comparatively speaking but they
do exist they are out there yet the left
has and some of them are quite dangerous
legitimately so which is what makes it
so unfortunate that the left has made
itself incapable of fighting real white
supremacy because it treats everything
as white supremacy this is the the thing
that I that for some reason left this
failed to grasp when you call everything
white supremacy when you call everything
racist when you call everything sexist
when you call everything homophobic on
and on and on then you're not going to
be left with any meaningful words to use
or meaningful labels to use when you
actually encounter those things for real
if you've called everything white if
it's if it's white if you're a white
supremists for trying to be objective
and you're going to call someone like
that a white supremacist then what are
you gonna say about the person who comes
along and actually says I think white
people are better than then than
everyone else and you know and and
people of other colors are inferior what
do you you just used white supremacists
on the guy who was talking about
objectivity what are you gonna say about
this guy well you're gonna call my white
supremacist too but you have just
basically let him off the hook because
you put him in the same category as that
other guy over there who was just making
a benign statement about about
objectivity you have made
so that you there's there's nothing the
meaningful you can say against white
supremacy because you have turned
everything in whites into white
supremacy and when everything is white
supremacy then nothing is white
supremacy anymore because the word has
no meaning that's the problem
all right two other things to get to
before we read some emails first with no
setup just watch this
I can't believe my student loan my
parents just got ghosted shouldn't no
pretty sure nothing long they say I'm
too young to raise my baby girl
take your opinions and Succot world
[Music]
yeah that's a that's a fast-food
commercial and they're doing this
because they want to promote mental
health this is a campaign for mental
health so they're renaming all of their
all these meals according to certain
moods and because it's gonna promote
mental health which which I have to say
you know I was feeling really depressed
but now that I can get a pissed meal at
Burger King everything is better you
know I I don't even have to go to
counseling Burger King has solved mental
health folks they've done it big news
finally speaking of mental health I
mentioned before that my wife has a
condition she has a problem really
she's as I mentioned before she's
addicted to decorative pillows and when
I talked about this in the past people I
think thought that I was exaggerating to
try to be funny well I want to show you
something so that you realize I'm not
exaggerated okay look at look at this
picture here just look at it we're doing
some spring cleaning you see those bags
there and my wife is relocating her
decorative pillow collection so those
bags all those bags are those bags are
filled with decorative pillows all of
those bags have pillows in them all
right
decorative not even real pillows not
pillows that we can use decorative
pillows and those you see those bags
those are just the pillows that are not
currently on display because those are
the non spring themed pillows oh yeah
she has a pillow for every season so
right now we've got the spring pillows
out those are the winter fall and summer
pillows so that's not even all the
pillows does that those are just um you
know 3/4 of the pillows if we trade it
in her pillow collection we could buy a
new car all I could say I hope is what I
was saying her last night I can only
hope that pillows appreciate in value
over time
because we aren't going to have any
other retirement savings with my wife
spending forty-seven thousand dollars a
month on pillows we're not going to have
anything else it's just it's it's really
a problem guys so you see what I'm
talking about I'm not you know I'm not
making this up
listen last week my wife said she was
going to the post office and I found her
six hours later lying in the aisle at
HomeGoods passed out from pillow fever I
mean I called her yesterday she was
chopping up pillows and trying to snort
them I mean literally okay but I didn't
those things didn't actually happen but
but but they might happen if we don't
get this woman to a rehab do they have
rehab centers for suburban white women
who are obsessed with home goods is that
is that a thing because that should be a
thing if it's not already all I'm saying
is you know she put those in trash bags
and I'm you know I'm not saying anything
III just I worry that those things are
in trash bags and there could be a
terrible mix-up wherein someone
accidentally thinks that those trash
bags are filled with trash and puts them
on the curb on trash day that could
happen it would be a terrible mistake I
just
it could happen though accidentally of
course then I would worry that my wife
might literally stab me in the face but
you know it might it might be worth it
just a declutter a bit all right Matt
wall show at gmail.com Matt wall show at
gmail.com is the email address this is
from well I'll keep this anonymous it
says hi mr. Walsh I'm emailing for your
advice on a moral dilemma I find myself
in the guy I eat lunch with every day at
work and I have become good friends for
a while we talked lightly about politics
I always assumed he had similar views to
mine based off what he said however I
was shocked the other day when he
started trying to convince me of the
anti-semitic theory that the Jews are
running the world at the time I didn't
know what to say so all I told him was I
think he's wrong and that a large part
of success that Jewish people comes down
to their values which their religion
inculcates in them however I still can't
shake this uncomfortable feeling I have
around this guy because I believe in to
be anti-semitic should I try to tell him
further why that viewpoint is dangerous
and wrong or should I just end
communication with him well I don't
think that we should
immediately dump people to the curb and
ostracize them for having views we
disagree with even if those are insane
and hateful views which anti-semitism is
so what I would do is I would continue
to talk with him and try to show him the
light a little bit as you've been doing
you know sometimes people maybe you
don't know a lot about this guy yet but
sometimes people will they'll have an
idea in there they'll be they'll be
harboring this idea but they don't say
it out loud because they're right Leah
shamed of it and then maybe one day they
finally do say it out loud because
they're kind of testing the idea they're
seeing if it holds up to scrutiny and
maybe that's what he was doing there you
know so I would give it some scrutiny
sometimes a person doesn't realize how
bad their idea is how stupid or
detestable until they've said it and
they've kind of put it out there for for
to be analyzed and argued against and
then they realize so I would do I would
do him the kindness do the service of
scrutinizing that idea and if he's an
honest guy then maybe he'll see that the
idea is stupid and and he'll drop it
it's possible it could happen and so
you've helped him out in that case I
would just saw I've just talked to him
ultimately if you find out that he
really is a committed passionate
unmovable anti-semite then maybe find
someone else to eat lunch with but I
wouldn't assume that right off the bat I
would try to maybe talk with him all
right this is from angeles's hi Matt the
more you listen your show the more I
enjoy it and respect you keep telling
truth and searching for the truth even
if it's unpopular two questions number
one if you if you shaved your beard do
you think your children would cry and
not recognize you
time for an experiment number two have
you been stung by your bees yet I I have
not been completely clean shaven since
my kids were born I don't remember the
last time I took like a Bic razor to my
entire face it's been probably was like
high schools last time although I have
in the past cut it down very short and
my kids were disturbed by that in fact
my my daughter thought that someone
stole my beard in the middle of the
night
and she may have thought that because I
told her that a gnome came in the middle
of the night and stole my beard and now
I have to go find it so I told her that
and she believes it as for being stung
by bees yes I have effect my first time
out with the high but I I was I had the
bee suit on I thought I felt very
confident you feel really powerful in a
bee suit like you know nothing can get
you but then I forgot that I I forgot
about the my feet and so be crawled down
in my shoe and stung my foot all right
this is from Patrick I started I started
reading this a few days ago and then I
stopped because I thought I already
answered it but then I was informed that
I did not already answer it so here it
goes from Patrick says future supreme
overlord and ruthless dictator of the
world I your humble and future servant
have a question for you I listen to your
show every day and notice you speak
about the importance of religion I
understand the importance of community
and morals but you don't need religion
to have those things my question is why
is religion so important I'm an agnostic
former Catholic person I think I'm a
very moral person without religion since
I am NOT Catholic I will undoubtedly be
executed when you rise to power I
consider it an honor and privilege to
die by your hand I only ask you make it
quick and painless thanks keep up the
good work
I really appreciate your your attitude
there Patrick and I cannot promise the
quick and painless part but III do again
appreciate the thought anyway as for
morals and community without religion
well are you sure I did not answer this
I feel like I've well I probably just
talked about this topic all the time
community yeah you can have community
without without religion you know all
many animals have have have form and
communities bees like women talking with
bees have communities ants have
communities so yeah you could have a
community in a sense without a religion
might not be a very strong community it
might not be a very meaningful community
but you can have them as for morals
though well this is the this is the
important distinction here that I think
sometimes atheists and agnostics
to see that nobody's claiming at least
I'm not claiming I don't think any
intelligent Christian claims that as an
atheist or agnostic you can't behave
morally that's not it's not what's being
said you obviously can behave in a moral
fashion as an atheist or agnostic I
assume you've never killed anybody
hopefully you don't steal things and
those sorts of things you know that it's
wrong to do those things you don't do
those things fine but the question is is
there any basis is there any objective
basis for moral action on the atheistic
worldview and then follow-up question is
yeah you seem to recognize what's right
and wrong and you can recognize those
things just as well as I can but where
do you think you get that recognition
from if it's entirely a social contrary
if it's just something that we come up
with as people then why is it that when
you look across the world and you look
at different civilizations you find
remarkably similar moral systems that
manifest themselves in in in starkly
different ways but if you look all
across the world everyone agrees
basically that murder is wrong everyone
basically agrees that rape is wrong
people still do those things in large
number but they recognize that it's
wrong to do it which is why almost
everywhere those actions are
criminalized so how did that happen you
know that's interesting isn't it and I
think as an atheist you have to have an
explanation for that and the explanation
as I said cannot be that it's all based
on you know social constructs because
then you would think you'd find
dramatically different moral systems in
the society in these different societies
but you don't find that we all seem to
agree why is that where did that come
from
and you can't say that it's it's all
evolution either because
seems to me that evolution is all about
survival of the fittest rights
evolution is doggy-dog strongest survive
I mean that's the that's the
evolutionary way whereas a lot of our
moral ideas fly directly against
evolution where we think morally that
for instance we're supposed to protect
the weak and the vulnerable from if we
were from a purely evolutionary
standpoint no the weak and vulnerable
should die because they're dragging the
rest of us down and we want only the
strong to survive but our moral system
has us go against that tide against that
the grain there as far as that goes
so again evolution is not a is not a
good explanation so I don't think you
can say that we evolved these moral
ideas I don't think you can say that
it's a social construct and where'd it
come from the answer of those from those
who believe in God is that this is this
moral intuition is endowed in us by God
and that God is the the grounding of
morality God is the foundation of all
morality and it flows from him and so we
as his creatures we and as rational
creatures we get that recognition from
him we understand it because God has
given it to us that that's the that's
the the theological answer to that
problem and it is you might not agree
with it but it is an answer anyway and
it seems to me that atheist and
agnostics don't have an answer so you
can behave morally as an atheist I don't
think you can come up with a coherent
objective basis for that moral behavior
without religion and that's the that's
the distinction all right we'll leave it
there thanks for watching everybody
thanks for listening Godspeed today on
the Ben Shapiro show Facebook borrows
Milo you Napoles louis farrakhan and
alex jones will talk about it that's
today on a bench Shapiro show